[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a África siete días
Este es su magazine 100% dedicado al
continente africano Mi nombre es Andrés
Meza Muñoz y Estos son nuestros
titulares mientras varios países
africanos se obtuvieron de votar a favor
de la resolución de la ONU que condena
la invasión rusa de Ucrania repasamos
los vínculos históricos entre Rusia y el
continente para intentar explicar la
posición de estos países
hablaremos también de la difícil
evacuación de los ciudadanos africanos
de Ucrania en su mayoría estudiantes
muchos de los cuales siguen varados en
el país en guerra finalmente iremos a
burkina faso en la frontera con gana
donde nuestro corresponsal siguió a los
guardaparques de la reserva de nasinga
que luchan por la protección de la
naturaleza pero también contra los
yihadistas cuyos ataques asolan la zona
el miércoles 2 de marzo en Nueva York la
asamblea general de las Naciones Unidas
aprobó por una abrumadora mayoría una
resolución condenando la que llamó
agresión contra Ucrania de los 193
estados miembros de la ONU 141 avalaron
el texto cinco países manifestaron su
oposición y 35 se ABS tuvieron entre
ellos 16 países africanos las
resoluciones de la asamblea general no
son vinculantes A diferencia de las del
Consejo de Seguridad pero tienen un
importante impacto simbólico en la
política internacional la negativa ha
condenar la agresión rusa no significa
su aprobación pero define un
posicionamiento ideológico claro veamos
en este mapa Cuáles son los países
africanos que se abstuvieron de condenar
la invasión de Ucrania por parte de
Rusia jugando declaró que se abstenía
para preservar su neutralidad junto a él
se encontraba Prácticamente todo el sur
de África desde tanzania hasta Angola
incluido el peso pesado del continente
Sudáfrica Por otra parte eritrea fue uno
de los únicos cinco países que votaron
en contra de la resolución mientras que
burkina fasol Guinea ki Etiopía Camerún
Marruecos y togo no participaron en el
voto Y es que la ausencia de condena de
la invasión de Ucrania por parte de
varios países africanos ha suscitado
muchas preguntas y la explicación puede
encontrarse en los vínculos históricos
entre Rusia y el continente en el pasado
Moscú y África han tenido una fuerte
relación de influencia en 1960 a
iniciativa de la unión soviética la
asamblea general de la ONU adoptó la
declaración a favor de la independencia
de los países colonizados más tarde A
mediados de la década de los 80 la unión
soviética afirmó cientos de acuerdos con
países africanos y unos 25.000
ciudadanos de este continente recibieron
capacitaciones en las universidades y
escuelas soviéticas en diversos campos
mientras que miles se graduaron en las
academias militares y políticas
soviéticas durante la Guerra Fría la
política soviética hacia África se
dirigía y apoyaba abiertamente a los
países cuyos líderes afirmaban su
compromiso con el socialismo a
principios de la década de 1990 el
colapso de la unión so rompió
prácticamente todos los lazos y puso
afín la misión ideológica opuso fin a la
misión ideológica de difusión del
socialismo de la URSS pero con la
recuperación económica de Rusia a
finales de los años 90 las relaciones se
restablecieron gradualmente en 2006 el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin visitó
Sudáfrica y Marruecos y en 2009 el ex
presidente ruso demitri realizó un viaje
oficial Angola namibia y Nigeria estas
visitas marcaron el comienzo de nuevas
relaciones bilaterales que culminaron en
la gran Cumbre Rusia África en Sochi en
octubre de 2019 con presidida por
Vladimir Putin y homólogo egipcio del
fata alcisie esta reunión soy yo
oficialmente el regreso de Rusia al
continente
actualmente la presencia rusa en África
no es solo económica sino también
militar e incluso se cree que es
paramilitar con la empresa de seguridad
privada Wagner echamos un vistazo a las
actividades rusas en el Continente en
este mapa podemos ver qué países
africanos han firmado contratos de
cooperación militar con Rusia Cuáles han
firmado contratos de cooperación en el
campo de la investigación nuclear en el
campo de la colaboración entre medios de
comunicación rusos y medios locales qué
operaciones mineras rusas están llevando
a cabo en el continente y en qué países
los contratos y actividades en el campo
de los recursos energéticos
exploraciones geológicas en el campo de
la agricultura así como la asistencia
rusa en términos de investigación médica
y de prevención de enfermedades
finalmente vemos dónde se concentran los
esfuerzos rusos para conseguir contratos
en el campo de las infraestructuras
con el mismo tema veamos ahora las
difíciles evacuaciones de los residentes
africanos en Ucrania mientras muchos de
ellos En su mayoría estudiantes intentan
llegar a los países vecinos al igual que
cientos de miles de ucranianos las
acusaciones de comportamientos racistas
en las fronteras sean multiplicado en
los últimos días los vídeos compartidos
en las redes sociales bajo el hashtag
africansing o africanos en Ucrania
muestran escenas de Gran tensión y
personas de África a las que se les
impide subir a los trenes que salen del
país escuchemos testimonios de una de
ellos
la mayoría de las veces consideran
primero la gente blanca los blancos
primero luego los que son de India y a
los árabes antes que los negros si eres
negro nadie te quiere ayudar
recuerdo que un policía en Ucrania le
dio un puñetazo a un hombre negro sin
que este haya hecho nada nada así que
como dije antes consideran a los blancos
antes de considerar a los negros
ante la multiplicación de este tipo de
testimonios la unión africana emitió El
lunes un comunicado en el que advertía
que aplicar un trato diferenciado a los
africanos es algo chocante y racista que
viola el derecho internacional en la
asamblea general de la ONU sobre Ucrania
algunos estados expresaron su acuerdo
con la declaración emitida por la
comisión de la unión africana escuchemos
a la embajadora de San Vicente y Las
Granadinas
antes de concluir señor presidente sería
negligente si no le expresara mi
consternación por los preocupantes
informes de que los afrodescendientes
están siendo tratados injustamente al
unirse a las masas que huyen del
territorio ucraniano a la luz del
derecho internacional y sus principios
rectores pedimos a todos los estados que
respeten sus obligaciones
internacionales y garanticen la
seguridad de todas las personas
cambiamos de tema y vamos ahora a Chad
un país de África Central situado en la
región del sail una de las más
inestables del mundo este país se
enfrenta a muchos desafíos en primer
lugar la seguridad o los conflictos
armados en los países de la zona Y en
segundo lugar el medio ambiente con la
aceleración de la desertificación en
términos de salud de Educación e
infraestructura el país sigue siendo
pobre y ocupa el último lugar en el
índice de capital humano del Banco
Mundial Y en este contexto de una nación
solo el 20% de la población sabe leer y
escribir un actor chadiano Lleva años
organizando lecturas teatrales en las
calles de la capital con el fin de traer
la cultura a los barrios populares
derribar los muros y las barreras es la
misión
delga desde hace años se organiza
lecturas teatrales en las calles de los
varios populares de la capital chayanna
y amena
la cultura debe ser accesible para todos
Si queremos tener un mundo bonito un
mundo armonioso todos debemos centrarnos
en las mismas dimensiones para poder
soñar juntos y sin cultura no podemos
iniciar el desarrollo y para comenzar la
etapa de desarrollo debemos invitar a
todos a pensar juntos las casas y los
callejones polvorientos y suceden pero
para el actor este entorno es un
escenario suficiente sus actuaciones
forman parte de una serie titulada una
lectura un viaje con diferentes temas el
del día es el exilio para abordarlo el
actor eligió Anymore Bena John Brown un
autor ya no nacido en 19 59 que abandonó
su tierra mientras la guerra civil de
los años 80 hacia estragos en el país
centroafricano escenario de numerosas
rebeliones desde su independencia de
Francia en 1960
el artista también evoca El Éxodo rural
y el desplazamiento de la población en
una nación asolada por los atentados
yadistas y los conflictos
intercomunitarios este país sinceridad
al mar de unos 15 millones de habitantes
no tiene ni teatro ni cine
ahora mientras hablo si él no está aquí
nuestros hijos lloran porque cada dos o
tres meses reúne a los niños les da
dibujos y demás Les enseña a jugar a
dibujar
así que me gusta que siga sigo nuestros
hijos con los jóvenes del barrio El
tercer país menos desarrollado del mundo
cerca del 42% de la población vive por
debajo del umbral de la pobreza según la
ONU
el 8 de febrero 9 guardabosques de la
ong african parks fueron asesinados en
un ataque yihadista en el parque W de
benín en la frontera con burkina faso
escasamente poblados y a menudo mal
controlados estos parques y bosques se
han convertido durante varios años en el
objetivo de los grupos yihadistas
nuestro corresponsal calidusis siguió a
un equipo de guardabosques en la reserva
nacinga en el sur de burkina faso cerca
de la frontera con ghana para contar el
riesgo que enfrentan en sus trabajos
a primera vista y sus compañeros
ataviados de equipo militar y armas
avanzadas podrían pasar por las fuerzas
de seguridad
que esta mañana se disponen a patrullar
para proteger los espacios naturales y
la lucha contra la caza furtiva
en un pueblo podemos tener un informante
que nos avise en cuanto se entera de que
hay cazadores furtivos nos llama y
llegamos a esta zona
esta área es el rancho de casa de
nashinga una enorme reserva natural de
casi 100.000 hectáreas ubicadas en la
región centro sur a 10 kilómetros de la
frontera con ghana en esta joya verde
las estrellas Son ellos los elefantes
[Música]
o habitan con miles de animales como el
coba el harvest o el cocodrilo pero en
2018 surge una nueva amenaza la
inseguridad vinculada a los grupos
armados cazan furtivamente para comer y
financiar sus actividades esto
secoguardias acompañados de
guardabosques desempeñan por tanto una
función crucial para la protección de la
vida Silvestre y las áreas forestales
desde la amenaza terrorista hemos
observado que hay muchas especies de
animales que están en peligro de
extinción en nasringa debido a la falta
de medios de vigilancia y a pesar de una
mejora muy marcada en los últimos dos
años la inseguridad todavía ha tenido un
impacto negativo en el turismo la
asistencia se ha reducido de 6000 a sólo
10 visitantes por año pero gracias al
trabajo de Benjamin bassono quien con su
ong apoya los servicios forestales para
la conservación y seguridad del parque
el área ahora es más segura
en 2019 hubo algunas inclinaciones de
ocupación pero inmediatamente logramos
recuperar los macizos forestales esto
nos permitió evitar la instalación de la
inseguridad en nuestra región hoy
decimos gracias a Dios que estamos a
salvo de Estas actividades terroristas
recuperación de la seguridad un
argumento esencial para reactivar el
turismo en la reserva de animales de
nasinga que alberga una de las mayores
poblaciones de elefantes de la sabana de
África occidental hasta aquí esta misión
de África siete días Gracias por
acompañarnos Recuerden que puede ver
este u otro episodio de nuestro programa
en nuestra página web www.24.com
[Música]